if welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thanks Dave glad to be here so what is
your net worth sir 2.8 million my name
is Jeff Foster and this is D my wife we
live in Buford Georgia which is a suburb
of Atlanta I think the majority of a
millionaires are more like us people
that have worked all their lives and
saved and guess where were millionaires
but you know we go to Walmart we have
the $20 James
I just basically come from a blue-collar
family I mean my dad worked 60 hours a
week my father was a janitor
he worked weekend's of painting houses
and throughout your working life time
what was your average income probably
about 125 K my very first year was
13,000 so early in my life I was a
computer technician and was doing well
and we had this major installation and
my 40-hour work we went to 80
so I started spinning on the 80-hour
level not the 40 and then the hours went
back but the habits that I've gotten
were pretty bad happens and so it took
me a while several months and paying
minimum on credit cards killed me I
hated it and so once I got to that point
that I got that debt paid off I said you
know no more never a few years go by and
and Dee and I get married the first year
is always a little bit of a challenge
right as newlyweds I came from a strict
family I'd already gone through my
challenges of how and when to use credit
cards yeah I didn't have a lot of my own
intention with money you know there
become a credit card problem right then
she was spending more than she could or
should from our you know family budget
at some point there the frustration went
kind of underground and she got her own
credit cards and started spending and
there was some you know probably a
couple of years very tense emotional
couple of years and so it got to a point
that you know it was almost at a divorce
level if you don't agree on something
you really need to speak up on it if it
leads to an argument so be it you're not
going to hash anything out and once you
talk about it if you don't sit down and
talk
you're never going to be on the same
page after we got on the same page we
were able to start doing more right and
as every every raise it came in a good
portion of that you know when it
retirement and so that's where we
started building that percentage from a
small number you know to a big number it
didn't know Dave Ramsey at the time but
ironically started following those kind
of principles and 5% in the 401k went to
6% went to 7% so being able to invest in
the 401k and buying mutual funds in in
multiple different companies very
similar to Dave Ramsey's perspective
today it's probably 25 or 30 percent of
my salary is going to retirement I think
it's probably been you know five or six
years since we've been a millionaire but
again it didn't change our lifestyle or
what we did or how we get it and so I
think that's the value it takes a long
time so a couple years ago when I
started listening to the Dave Ramsey
podcast it kind of reconfirmed in a lot
of cases of things that I was already
doing but it made some adjustments and
it kind of think it even helped her more
and you know seeing this is not my way
it's lots of people's way and then we
then you know went to the kids in both
kids Eric and Tina
both read Total Money Makeover
and it's like okay yeah I did what you
said dad I read the book but didn't
their work trips but you know where we
would have a family trip there were
hunting trips where Eric and I went or
Tina and I went that deer came from
Indiana and there were you know if it's
a Colorado it's a 24 hour drive lots of
Dave Ramsey segments one hour segments
can be heard in 24 hours our kids and
our friends and relatives are really
starting to catch on
on the fundamentals of the seven baby
steps if you're you know at least
getting through steps one two and three
then you know you're moving in the right
direction and you know in the future
maybe you can get all the way to steps
of it looking even more forward now I
expect to pretty close double my wealth
that I have today in the next five to
six years but it is less about doubling
the money and more about leaving a
legacy to my children to my friends we
want to be able to share the same
newborn failures that we've done and the
successes that we've had and to be able
to share that so they can you know you
know be able to be just as successful as
us so leaving the legacy of who we are
what we do how we do it and being able
to share that experience is you know in
40 both of us being a millionaire means
knowing I'll be comfortable when he
quits working but knowing that I don't
have to worry about where my next meal
is coming from or where I'm going to
live that's basically what a million
areas to me
you